so we are good to go welcome back to
machine learning street talk
um we don't even do these formal
introductions anymore but in the olden
days i always used to say you know with
mit phd dr keith duggar uh now we're
much more casual because we're doing the
unplugged versions but um anyway uh here
uh today we've got yazaman razeghi and
professor samir singh and um i've been
huge fans of your work and professor
singh in particular for many years i've
been following your work but would you
mind both introducing yourselves so i'm
yasaman i'm a phd student in uc irvine
it's been almost a bit more than two
years that i've been working in nlp and
mostly i've been working with
language models
oh hi tim yeah thanks thanks for having
us this is this is exciting um i'm samir
singh i'm associate professor here at uc
irvine i also work as an ai fellow at
ai2
and yeah i'd like to do a lot of stuff
with explaining testing and doing
robustness testing of language models so
excited about get into all that uh today
indeed and it's one of my passions i've
been uh building ml devops systems over
the years and um that there's so much
attention that i've placed on on your
work samuel i'm excited actually just to
be speaking with you in real life but um
but first of all a yazo man
you've done some really interesting work
recently and um i'm trying to think of
the best way for us to uh decompose this
in into into bite-sized chunks for our
audience but you recently uh put out a
paper called impact of pre-training uh
term frequencies on few shot reasoning
and um yazman in particular that there's
a very famous graph which of course you
posted on twitter to much acclaim could
you start by just giving us a bit of an
outline of the paper and and explaining
that graph
sure so
it is started by us seeing that these
pre-trained large language models are
getting pretty good results in reasoning
and more specifically numerical
reasoning tasks
about that graph for example
in in context learning like only putting
a few examples of training data
we saw that language models like gptj
can get a really good results in
answering some multiplication questions
so we were interested to see how much of
this multiplication or numerical
reasoning is actual robust reasoning
given that they have been pre-trained on
a huge amount of pre-training data
so to do that as an example on the graph
you mentioned we have like what is 24
times x or what is 23 times x so we
looked at the pile pre-training data of
these illustrator ai models
and
counted how many times did what we call
terms like numbers of 23 and 24 appeared
in that pre-training data and how much
does this impact the accuracy of the
models in answering this multiplication
question
we found a strong correlation between
the model's performance on these test
instances and their corresponding 10
frequencies which somehow tells us that
this is not robust reasoning going on
and we should be more
careful of saying how much these
language models are capable of mate
okay that that's absolutely fascinating
so why don't we start by saying um
if the models were in fact reasoning and
maybe we should unpack reasoning as well
so i think there's a real problem in
machine learning that we're obsessed
with the behavioral outputs of a model
and we create metrics to represent it
but sometimes models do the right thing
for the wrong reason so it's really
important how the models do what they do
and and in this case
advocates of these large language models
will say oh look it's multiplying
numbers together but um it's quite easy
to show that they don't work outside of
the training range and and your work
here shows quite clearly i think that
there's a hypothesis that these models
are trained memorizing the training set
but but anyway
what would this graph look like
um you know if if the opposite was true
if if they were reasoning
so this is a hard question like we have
an example of converting decade two
years that it actually gets into perfect
accuracy
and if
when we get to perfect accuracies or the
graph is just a simple line
if that's reasoning or not
i'm not sure still but what we advocate
is that we should have more studying and
to measures of robustness and make sure
that what is happening by this graph we
can just say
this is
not maybe reasoning but
we should think about what we expect of
the reasoning itself that's as you said
i think i guess one example we have in
the paper uh is with addition where when
we tried the biggest model uh and with i
think most number of shots the line was
pretty high it wasn't all the way to 100
but it was pretty high and it was pretty
flat and that's kind of the behavior i
expect if you're at least robust to
unigram statistics on the training data
but there may be higher order statistics
that you're still susceptible to and so
i i can think about a more robust model
what it might look like but it's
difficult to say that it is at that
point completely doing robust reasoning
right and i think in your paper first of
all thank you for writing this paper
like i sincerely mean that because i i
think you bring up this absolutely
crucial point that the pre-training data
has to be considered when when you're
talking about the performance of the
model and i think in my opinion this
paper
directly strikes that and proves it's
not doing reasoning you know because
like you say
this this flat line you know the
performance a lack of a performance gap
in other words no matter what examples
you give it it doesn't matter how well
they're represented in the in the
training in the training debt uh data
set if it's actually reasoning it'll be
able to perform you know uniformly
across that but you point out this is
just a necessary condition
for reasoning it's not necessarily
sufficient because for small problems
you could memorize the whole thing and i
think what amazed me is is this note
that you had in the paper and it says
here
note that even quote rare terms overall
their frequency was still on the order
of millions in the pre-training data set
and i mean for me it's a bit
disappointing that even with millions of
examples okay of every single pairing of
two-digit multiplication
these massive massive models still
cannot learn to perform
two-digit multiplication like i mean am
i being unfair or is that a fair point
um
just just to make sure this millions is
the frequency of the unigram statistics
like 23 by itself and it's not like the
whole multiplication question but that
note says that
it's not the language model does not
know enough 23 versus 24. when we are in
the order of the millions
this shouldn't be that much of the
matter in terms of the correlations
right because even with millions of the
unigrams you still got at least 10 000
you know of of the individual pairings
right
yeah so i mean am i be unfair or i would
say it's totally fair like i i think
when we started with this stuff we were
like hey let's try the unigram
statistics first but clearly we might
see a trend but it won't be so strong
and and the fact that even with
kindergarten statistics it's so strong
definitely makes us feel like hey some
something strange is is going on here
right especially with the
discourse last year over these being
foundational models and and you can use
them to build other systems on top of it
um it becomes even more crucial like how
much does this model know about 23
versus 24 and
and if there is a strong bias and it
seems to know 24 a lot more than 23 that
might have real world sort of
consequences
if you think about these as foundational
models
yeah i just thought of a really
interesting interplay because later on
samuel we're going to talk about the
some of the perils of of metrics because
they they oversimplify what is very
complex system but in in this case this
is an example of a very good use of a
metric i think to understand what's
going on but i wanted to just quickly
get into what i see as some of the
zealotry around some of these large
language models i mean at yazman
let's point out the elephant in the room
right so you've just done this critical
piece of analysis and it is amazing
which open ai should have done in the
first place they should have presented
their results in respect of the size of
the training corpus and they should have
shown how corpus dependent the results
in fact are and as far as i'm aware they
never released concrete details about
the corpus which made it very difficult
to reproduce many of their results and
as i understand most of the leutha's
models and even many of the subsequent
large language models released by other
companies
underperformed gpt3 it's only now that
google have released their pathways
models that we're seeing supra gbt3
level performance now um thomas wolfe of
hugging face fame recently admitted on
twiml
you know the other podcast uh the
competing podcast um that um it's the
data set and how it's curated which
overwhelmingly determines the
performance of the downstream language
tasks by the way he tweeted yesterday
saying that large language models are
slightly boring um i don't want to sound
cynical yes a man but i'm pondering
right i'm pondering why open ai have
been so guarded about this simple fact
right the thought occurs that it might
be because they want us to believe that
the models are actually doing something
other than simply memorizing the data
the further thought occurs that some of
these folks might be true believers
right in this overzealous notion that
these models are slightly conscious or
indeed a manifestation of some kind of
emergent intelligence yes man i think
your work is a bit of a reality check
what's your take
this is a hard question but i think
they do not have that much of a context
consciousness as you said and but they
they work in some ways if you give me a
leaderboard and wanted me to stop me to
get the highest score on that
leaderboards i definitely do use this
language model
if you ask me to use
these language models for a very
sensitive application i would be very
careful about that so
my paper says just be realistic about
what they can do and what they cannot
and i guess that's the point that we can
start build upon it
yeah i guess when it comes to open ai i
you know i i don't work with them or
anything like that but
from what i can tell it's it's more of
the latter amongst the two you said tim
where i think it's more about uh just
thinking that these things work and then
they do their
you know good effort let's not call it
best effort they do a good effort of
evaluation so even this memorization
stuff they had this version um
which uh i think stella from luther
pointed us to um where they sort of do a
search for how much the test set
overlaps with the training set but in
terms of like really high end grams
right
13 grams right so do you literally see
the whole sequence as almost as it is um
in the trading data and they tried that
and didn't see quite a big uh overlap
there um but i think that's testing
slightly different thing than we are and
so when you try testing unigram stuff
which you know might just be something
too obvious for them to have
considered or you know whatever uh it is
um i wouldn't sort of say that
the fact that they didn't test
memorization more is is somehow uh
yeah it is just something that missed i
guess
well i guess
one really important um i think thing
about this work is again since it points
at the importance of the pre-training
corpus
the pre-training and this knowledge of
how it's impacting really the
performance the frequency you know that
it's doing this kind of memorization can
be used for both good or ill so so
number one i think it could be used for
people to better design
um the corpus so that it can actually
perform better you know we don't need
a thousand examples of 24 times three
but we need to show it some different
types of examples in order for it to
memorize like the right structures and
so maybe even with less data we can get
better better flat line kind of kind of
performance and even higher performance
on the other hand if we just ignore this
like if we just ignore the importance of
the pre-training corpus it opens the
door to all kinds of data poisoning
whether or not we you know it was
intentional or not i mean so somebody
can just start putting things on the
internet so that the next time we train
gpt3
it does a bunch of stuff that we don't
want it to do you know because now i
poisoned like the internet corpus with
stuff right because i understand now the
math if you will behind how the
pre-training affects it and so we've got
to learn about this like we really have
to study it so that we can guard against
it as well as use it for for good is
that right
of course that's actually why we did
this research
i we cannot say specifically
memorization is bad it can make language
models know a lot of facts
and maybe sometimes we intentionally
want this language model to memorize
everything
in terms of generalization or reasoning
we show
it's not good and as you mentioned it
can be good and bad
consequences in terms of poisoning and
other things i can think of yeah i guess
what i would say is that this is you
know somewhat of a in a traditional
machine learning sense it's somewhat of
a very obvious statement to make is if
you're trading a model on something you
should know what you're trading on and
then somehow with gpt three and even
gpt2 like there were details about where
the training data comes from that were
sort of omitted and and
if anything this this paper shows that
we should at least be transparent about
the period in corpus right um
how much we can do an analysis how much
we can control it how much we can detect
poisoning are all exciting research
questions but we cannot even
start answering those questions till we
have the pre-training corpus right so
if this paper sort of helps the
conversation in saying like let's
everybody try to release pre-training
corpus and maybe build better tools to
be able to analyze it um i think i would
be very happy
on the other hand it may also it may
also create the incentive for
proprietary you know even more
proprietary data sets because now if we
agree how important the pre-training
data set is well some some groups out
there are going to decide exactly that's
why i'm going to keep mine secret
because it's a it's a competitive
advantage now
i i wanted to talk a little bit about
metric theater and sotter chasing right
so um
linguist professor emily bender she
tweeted yesterday that machine learning
is over-funded and has a culture of
solving problems and dismissing domain
expertise she said that ml has a huge
incentive to stomp all over everything
else with minimal accountability leaving
a mess for others and i think by others
she meant her to clean up
she took particular umbrage with all of
the unsubstantiated claims of surpassing
human performance on a particular task i
think it gets back to this basic problem
we see every day right which is the
metric theater problem so just because
some trivial and vacant metric says that
your complex system is behaving
correctly it doesn't mean the actual
system right is doing the thing that you
want it to do for the right reasons
isn't this just like a problem we have
in natural language processing across
the board
so i i really like looking at different
kind of metrics in various aspects like
when we see good results we see how
models are getting into those results
how transparent are they
i guess
of course i really like having these
kinds of analysis and that's why i've
been doing most probing the stuff with
these language models other than trying
to make them get better results
yeah i think i think what i will add is
that this the thing that happens with
this metric theater um i guess i don't i
don't sort of necessarily think like
comparing against human performance on a
data set is a bad thing by itself right
like i think it's a useful
human performance is a maybe a useful
metric for what the best any sort of
machine learning model should be able to
do on this specific data set um and when
you do get really high accuracy you
you have to be just really careful about
what statement that sort of implies and
the thing with metric theater is that
better than humans sort of ends up
becoming a proxy for something more than
just the fact that you got a few
instances correct it ends up sort of
having all kinds of uh you know
conclusions are made about what the
model's generalization capabilities are
beyond that simple descent
and that's the part of
the whole metric theater that sort of
you know sometimes takes us a little bit
back backwards uh i guess the
you know like the squad question
answering data set which came out i
guess at six seven years ago at this
point um
that data set was really useful way of
posing question answering um but it took
a long time and we got pretty good and
better than humans um within three or
four years um but it took a really long
time for us to be
realized that not all of this progress
was towards better reading comprehension
and there was memorization and sort of
lexical stuff that was happening all
kinds of shortcuts
and so when metrics become the primary
thing people look at the analysis and
everything else has to play catcher
and i feel that's what is happening with
yasman's work as well where the claims
are much beyond where these models
actual capabilities lie
and and we are sort of still trying to
catch up as to how accurate these things
actually are
so that's that's i guess what uh emily
also probably meant is like yeah we have
to clean up the mess in terms of
figuring out actually what is working
and what is not
yeah and it's and as you you mentioned
there are some it's important to have an
understanding of how the machines
are working and i think we're probably
going to get into the explainability you
know kind of questions maybe a bit later
but back to kind of the human parity
let's say um
it is if we all agree that humans are
generally intelligent you know some
people argue that maybe they are but
let's suppose we are uh it is the only
extant example that we have of a
generally intelligent you know system
and one that's you know capable of
reasoning in general over over a huge
domain of problems and as you said in
the paper
reasoning is still ill-defined
and
lack of a performance gap is a necessary
but not sufficient condition for that
i'm curious among the various
definitions of reasoning that are put
forth in the community
do you have a favorite one or a favorite
class or even a favorite direction in
which people are trying to
explore better defining reasoning
whether it's looking at how humans are
doing it or more a mathematical approach
like talking about type behaviors class
behaviors like what do you if you had to
guess
what a good definition of reasoning
would be in the future what would it
look like
i i read a lot about what's happening in
the reasoning and because for a long
time we wanted to answer the question if
we can separate reasoning from knowledge
while we are doing reasoning through
language
i don't think i have a favorite
definition of what is actual complete
reasoning but
there are some
necessary conditions that i can think of
that
at least they be robust they follow some
mental models as we have as a human
and
uh
we can we can uh
we can trust that reasoning process by
following the rules happening in between
i guess
i guess i think i like benchmarks where
they're really trying to push towards
stuff that the model would not have seen
during pre-training um and and try to
solely sort of focus on that and it's
that's really difficult even if you
don't have access to the pre-training
corpus but even with access superior
corpus that that's not really that easy
um but the way i think about it is there
is something that should be very very
contextual from the input itself
where the model really needs to
understand what's happening in the input
rather than realize something on the
pre-training um and the more it has to
rely on the on understanding the input
itself the the better i would feel
comfortable about calling it reasoning
so as some examples i think um
we we also did this because we like this
example quite a bit uh but the
operation inference um test that we have
where you're given two numbers and
you're given some weight
operation placeholder between those
numbers but you don't know what this
operation placeholder actually does or
what operation it carries out but you're
given a few examples of what the results
should be
and this would i imagine something that
would be
on tests for kids or like sort of
puzzles rather than than actual um
exams and then based on those examples
you figure out okay the operation is
addition or multiplication or what have
you uh and you have to figure that out
so that
that we we saw
you know we did see some memorization
effects but that seems a little bit
closer to what i would expect uh
reasoning to look like um
you you
i could still imagine that there are
memorization effects there but you can
push that forward you can even replace
numbers with other things and you can
you have to guess the numbers as well uh
in general i like these sort of solving
these puzzles and i could imagine
eventually solving these puzzles would
be a good way
to do test reasoning the one um
i guess the one limitation of this
direction is that you can quickly get
into fairly abstract reasoning puzzles
and problems and
they may not be the most pragmatic
things when you're talking about
downstream applications and real world
use cases um and so
you you have to be aware about that as
well
and for real world use cases the the
main way to think about this is
you're introducing a scenario in that at
the at this time that you may not have
seen during pre-trading and see if the
model is able to reason about all kinds
of consequences of of that new scenario
like say hey what if the gravity was
half or
what if uh
the sky was red you know you can sort of
ask the model to uh
reason about what the consequences of
these uh these things might be
well let me let me challenge one thing
on that because
i did i did look carefully at the
operator inference one because i found
that fascinating problem and
i saw a pretty robust still you know
performance gap except in the areas
where it basically just couldn't do it
at all or it was just abysmal you know
kind of flat performance and so
the takeaway i'm getting from from all
the charts that you had in the paper is
that this finding of
um a performance gap or rather that the
the pre-training corpus you know
frequency
has a you know very strong relationship
to performance
seems very robust except in the case
where one
it's doing a terrible terrible job and
maybe just kind of guessing or where the
problem is so simple that it was in fact
able to just memorize
you know the mappings um
i'm curious
how you could even disentangle let's say
the complexity slash simplicity of the
problem versus this this dependence that
you're seeing on the the pre-training
corpus
i guess that's the re one of the main
reasons we cannot uh
we cannot answer what is difficult for
language models actually so for in terms
of
multiplication our hypothesis was that
if it knows the multiplication rules
then it can answer but
as we talked maybe about that flat line
when they get when the models gets
really good
in terms of performance really accurate
or on the other side really bad it's
hard to detangle accuracy versus this
effect and
i think we should do more
maybe causal
uh research to see what is the effects
on pre-training how does that look like
like how we should
look in how we should change the
pre-training data to make some kinds of
causal inferences here
i think something that we should more
study on this but as you said detangling
these accuracies with the effects is
something hard and we couldn't do this
end of it
i wanted to come back a little bit to
this question of of metrics so there's a
bit of a culture especially in the tech
industry of blind empiricism and
obsession with metrics and kpis and it
was after i read kenneth stanley's book
why greatness can't be planned and
there's also another book called the
tyranny of metrics
and they speak about a few problems with
metrics so for example deception is the
biggest one which is that there's a
false compass and it leads you in the
wrong direction um either because of
missing information or because it's a
complex system and you can't represent
the thing also the shortcut rule which
is you get exactly what you optimize for
at the cost of everything else and also
a good heart's law which is that you
know that you you gain the system as
soon as you optimize on it and probably
lots of other things that we don't have
time to go into now so um it seems like
metrics are quite problematic but i i i
find myself having this discussion with
people recently and and people are
saying to me tim you're being
anti-intellectual you know you're being
unscientific
um i mean how else could we
without benchmarks how else could we
actually get everyone on the same page
and and make something which is
genuinely um doing what we want it to do
so i i mean i think um
i think the metrics are very useful
things right so i would never advocate
against using uh aggregate metrics um or
or whatever metrics you have and in fact
the more you have the the better it is
uh the only thing i would say is that
the the scope of what you conclude from
these metrics has to be has to be clear
right so science has been empirical for
the longest time and then that's been
great um but there has been a strong of
like okay we're doing we're doing
hypothesis and then we're going to be
testing that hypothesis and the metrics
are serving as a yes or no answer to
that hypothesis
right
well i mean the the thing is though that
um so the problem with deception is that
the the metrics blind you from
discovering and you know new hypotheses
or new stepping stones and i think
people like emily bender would make the
argument that we're so obsessed with
monotonically optimizing these
objectives
it's not it's not only the objectives i
think as
sarah hooker would say with the hardware
lottery it's also our investment in
technology which is kind of blinding us
from discovering new interesting
stepping stones so it does feel like
we're in this basin of attraction right
that's true yeah and so i guess where i
was going was that uh metrics shouldn't
be the sole way of of evaluating these
things and then that's kind of what what
we've been doing is like yeah they're
useful they're at the sort of very far
away looking at it from you know eagle
eye vision or something you just sort of
get a picture of okay these things are
doing roughly better than these other
things uh but it's really important to
to sort of develop into why they're
doing it and and what's going on in
there and even what you're computing
metrics over and i think this this last
part tends to get uh sort of you know
people don't tend to focus on that uh
they're like hey you get an accuracy
number and that that's it but looking at
exactly what what you're evaluating uh
is key
um
and you know and in this in yasman's
paper how much that overlaps with with
the training data right so uh maybe
going forward i would be a lot more
comfortable if we still talk about
metrics sometimes but take into account
for example like remove stuff that
overlaps a lot with the pre-training
corpus suddenly those the remaining now
if you tell me if it's still 90
that suddenly makes me feel a little bit
more comp confident than it would
otherwise right so i think um you know
metrics are just numbers so the main
goal is to figure out what you're
testing it on and are you testing the
right thing and are you testing enough
of the right thing
another thing i wondered about is there
are some incredibly smart people out
there who really really believe that
there's something interesting about
these large language models i mean i've
i've got an incredibly good friend of
mine uh connor leahy from oloitha ai i'm
having dinner with him on friday evening
and when we speak about um all of these
matters he says uh tim um let's ban the
use of the word reasoning and tim
intelligence is a suitcase word let's
not talk about that and you you know
what these how these conversations go
they've always got an answer for
everything usually invoking uh appeals
to infinity whether it's the you know
touring completeness or you know
universal function approximation and you
know these are incredibly intelligent
people it's almost like the more
intelligent you are the more you can
kind of delude yourself that there's
something magic going on um just
wondered if you had any any thoughts
about that
and one point i guess there these
language models are getting impressive
results
their applications and how robust are
are they are pretty narrow but i think
going on adding some other things like
neural symbolic models or these kinds of
stuff
they should add up together it's not the
way that
there is only one way to reach some
intelligence
i i know but this isn't this this is the
um the epitome of what i'm talking about
with deceptive metrics because the
metrics look good but
intelligence is like pornography i know
it when i see it right it's obvious that
this thing isn't intelligent
well tim like maybe i can throw
something in here which to me
google is kind of the and i mean the
search engine is is almost the modern
form of
searle's chinese room you know and in
fact when i used to be involved in all
kinds of flame wars on uh usenet i i
coined this word called wikipedicated
you guys can actually look it up on
urban dictionary somebody put it there
because i would be having these back and
forths on news groups with people
and i would put something what they
would do is go read some wikipedia
article or google up something on the
internet and then just kind of dump
whatever they found in there sort of in
response to me right all they're doing
is just grabbing information they don't
actually have knowledge and i'm
wondering if you just put me in a room
and say told somebody that that you were
talking to gpt3
if i was fast enough on a keyboard they
asked me the question i copy and paste
it in google i go
locate some answer even randomly and
paste it back you know it'd be almost
the same level of performance right
yeah so i think those are the really
good points uh what i will say is i i
guess sort of thinking about why we are
where we are um
the
what has happened sort of in the last
decade as we've gone from things that we
cannot imagine ever working or like
generation being an actual thing and and
being able to be so good compared to
humans on these benchmarks uh
and
these this we've sort of gotten where we
are very fast um
at a speed that has been difficult for
the community to digest like okay what's
actually uh
what's actually going on in these models
what are they capable of what are they
not capable of
both empirically and theoretically right
so if you take a slightly step back and
look at the trends and you're like okay
performance on arithmetic test okay it's
clearly going in one direction for
performance or generation okay it's
going up and so it's very reasonable to
say okay just looking at those charts we
can sort of extrapolate and say yeah
that's that's the way for intelligence
um and i guess what i want to say is
that i'm not claiming that
this is not or this is the way way to
get insurgents uh just to say that
we are not just not evaluating it
properly right now so there is no way
for us to know whether we can trust
these charts and do the extrapolation
and do things like that right like maybe
this this thing is still the right way
to go and and but the thing is we can't
claim that either way very confidently
till we have better
understanding and evaluation of these
benchmarks right so um
yeah maybe two legit edition is solved
and maybe it is actually doing it
internally with the neural ones but
there is no real way to test that or
claim that right now
in indeed well that leads me nicely on
on to the next subject so i wanted to
get into your work a little bit samir
i've been a huge follower of your work
um after i discovered marco ribeiro i i
interviewed marco back in 2019 uh when i
watched him do a presentation on online
line by the way which he co-authored
with him is um lemme's from his locally
invariant model agnostic explanation so
it's this whole idea of model validation
is it's a local form of model
explainability where you take an example
and then you kind of perturb you do some
domain-specific perturbation in the
neighborhood of that example and then
you build a linear model to
sort of represent how those
perturbations affect the classifier and
there's visual mod versions of it and
language versions of it and so on but
you know i find i found that absolutely
fascinating and even more fascinating is
is you and marco started talking about
counter factual reasoning which i want
to get to in a minute but um maybe we
should start with lime i have to be
honest with you semi so i'm i've i was
obsessed with lime and things like
shapley values and i've i've done a lot
of work with data scientists in my
career and we talk a good game about
model validation and reasoning about
behavior of the models and i must i must
say samia i mean you are the
when it comes to reasoning about the
behavior of the model you're you're the
guy but i have to be honest with you and
say
with things like lime and chap and
shapley values everyone talks about them
but no one uses them um just wondered if
you had any thoughts on why that was
yeah no i think so you know just just to
be clear when we introduce lime we
we were very excited about it and again
again it's one of those things where
what it produces comes with a bunch of
caveats and and you know like
we didn't know the extent to which those
caveats should be when when time was
introduced uh it was solving a really
important problem i guess solving is
difficult to say it was trying to
address a really important problem and
and with a fairly simple
uh solution that that works sometimes
and doesn't work other times right and
we we showed some ways it worked
otherwise it didn't work and then a lot
of work has
sort of built up on that to show
other ways that it works and other ways
it does not work right so
just like you know human beating human
comes should come with some caveat as to
what that even means um using lime for
your application and what the
explanations it generates uh need to
come with some sort of caveat of like
okay this is the extent to which we are
able to explain stuff and and if that
caveat is um
sort of below your tolerance for how
much of a guarantee you need then lime
becomes um not very useful for you right
so i think
uh for us personally as researchers we
we started playing around with lime sort
of ideas
um you know this was 2015-ish
where these deep learning models were
just doing really well and we were
ourselves curious why they were working
so well and at that time the discourse
was not so much on like short cuts and
spheres correlations and things like
that it was about look these just these
things are just working
and
the most surprising thing about lime for
us at that time was it just showed all
of these problems with the models um
that we didn't
think would be the case and when we
would test those issues out we would
realize that oh these actually um
these actually are problems in the
models right so i think lyme ended up
being fairly useful for that kind of
analysis but just like any other
analysis you shouldn't trust an accuracy
number
or you should take it with some grain of
salt similarly explanations should also
be taken with some grain of salt lyme in
particular gives you a certain style of
explanations
and the whole idea of what is an
explanation is ill-defined enough
everybody comes with their own
uh
need for what an explanation is and lyme
doesn't satisfy maybe many of them
yeah what what i find interesting about
the the caveats uh comments you made
there um
uh sometime back where we were talking
to christoph molnar about about
interpretive interpretable machine
learning explainability and whatnot and
we were looking through the various uh
ways in which were popular at the time
to do that and i think i made a comment
something like it's like we're using
complex mathematics to explain complex
mathematics right and and there is
there's almost this this irreducibility
sort of in the the wolfram style of
computational irreducibility it's like
you know the problem itself
is complicated and there's no way to
make it simpler and so even if you come
up with a simple metric of some kind it
has these caveats that really take a
professional such as yourself to
understand and apply and use as a tool
to learn things but are we just in a
state where
some some analysis some problems the
solution to them is just irreducibly
complex and there is no really
simple way um to visualize or express um
the decision boundaries yeah that's a
really really good question and that
also goes at heart of what even an
explanation is and and what you're
trying to sort of explain uh i think
when life was introduced the the sort of
target audience was machine learning
experts who
who could understand okay you're doing a
linear approximation of a local region
and the feature importances are just the
linear weights that you're assigning
those features and you know like
familiarity with
logistic regression would tell you to
what extent you can understand or how to
interpret those
feature importances but if you ask
someone slightly outside the
ml expertise
area
about what it means for something to be
important
they'll disagree they'll not have a
precise definition
um they'll you know it sort of gets into
this world where
you know complexity of uh the
explanation ends up being tricky um so
what i
think would be nice um from an
explanation point of view is to have a
simple question right so however complex
the model might be have a hypothesis or
have a simple question that has a yes or
no answer or
something that that is very easy to
summarize um
and then let's let's work on uh
methods that are able to give you that
answer right and then if you're able to
sort of
condense down expirability or the needs
of actual users into what those precise
questions could be
um i think explainability would be much
much more useful lying to that end is is
on the side where
it's not clear what question what
precise question it is giving a yes or
no answer to because it's not giving a
yes or no answer well i mean the the
only disadvantage to that is uh then
then you wind up so you boil everything
down
to some set of yes or no questions it's
never gonna go down to one then you're
basically at this decision tree right
and sure people do like those because
for example i i don't know i go to get
my car insurance renewed and it goes up
by
200 bucks and i'm like why'd this happen
well you got this speeding ticket you
know so i can i can blame it all on that
you know if i had just not gotten that
speeding ticket where in fact there's a
bunch of other variables that if the
answers were yes to them you know even
if i had gotten that speeding ticket it
might have stayed low and so it makes it
it's almost deceptive you know back to
tim's kind of deception point it's
deceptively simple because i can find
the one question that i could have
changed that
you know my life and gotten the loan or
whatever else but it's really not the
full picture
yeah i think it ends up sort of
depending on what the use cases are and
and and i guess how
accurate the explanations are so if the
explanation says it's because of that
speeding ticket and it's actually a
bunch of other factors um then i would
say that explanation should come with
those
saying like hey there are 10 other
factors uh but the most
uh speeding ticket was the most
important one and that's the one that
would explain i don't know
uh 150 out of that 200 increase or
something like that
yeah it's fascinating we could go so
deep here because i think we could talk
about um the consistency of the
explanations and um
uh
you know the understandability of the
explanations i think is where we were
going before because people talk about
this notion of white box models being
understandable for example if they if
they don't have too many um uh you know
attributes
but um i wanted to get into ml devops a
little bit so one of the things that
really intrigued me about for example
your checklist approach is um there's a
huge dichotomy between science and
engineering and one of the big
bottlenecks i mean there are many
interactive processes that need to
happen as part of devops and we want
data scientists to be first-class
citizens in the software engineering
life cycle but one of the biggest
bottlenecks is the model validation
process
and it's much more mature now than it
was in the past so for example people
might use weights and biases and they
might do their model validation they
might produce explanations or saliency
maps or lime or whatever it is and
they'll kind of immortalize it in in in
um a model report if you like and then
that will be approved and immortalized
and then we'll kind of hand off to the
non-interactive phase of the process so
what really intrigued me about checklist
is for the first time we have a
non-interactive way of reasoning about
model behavior and potentially failing a
build if things don't look right um i
think we can move into something a bit
more sophisticated which is coming up
with an active learning feedback loop
but why don't we just start with that
non-interactive piece first do you think
that's an important part of ml
engineering
i think it is and then we can talk about
the interactive stuff but the thing i
like about um the way checklist
approaches these things is it's not
necessarily tied to the model but it's
more about the task itself right so um
this this is a more common practice in
software engineering and not so much in
machine learning uh where you sort of
have a set of specifications that you
want to hit when you're building a piece
of software a piece of complex software
and checklist has that style of approach
to testing right like hey you wanted to
set up an analysis sit down spend some
time get some experts uh
of the users or the domain that you're
looking into and sit down and think
about what what a specification is or
what the minimum specification
is um and that part of non-interactivity
is actually useful um because you're
sort of thinking at a high level what
what the actual goals would be um
of course it gets restricted in the
sense that you might be testing a lot of
things that are trivial for the model
uh it turned out surprisingly not the
ones we came up with uh but also you
might uh go into this whole
uh rabbit hole of trying to come up with
things that are at least very little not
very relevant to the domain just just
for the task of coming up with these
tasks and finally you might just be
restricted in the creativity of uh of
how good the tests are so here i would
say like marco was the one who came up
with the tests and
i expect he he was extremely creative
about coming up with those um the
utility of checklist kind of gets
constrained by who is the one who is
coming up with the tests and and i or
someone else may not be quite as
effective uh or as creative as as those
tests as mark was and so
um
that dependence on the user itself and
what their incentives
are in testing um can sometimes make
these things a little bit more well what
occurs to me now is uh
yazman's work can be used to actually uh
be pulled into
some form of machine driven testing as
well where it says okay you tell me what
pre-training you know data you use and
i'm going to conduct an analysis which
based off of this kind of frequency of
occurrence will generate you know test
examples
that uh you'll probably fail unless you
learned xyz kind of capabilities that we
require of this system
like osmond do you see the possibility
yes like
like one question that they were
thinking about is that for numerical
reasoning
it was somehow like
to us somehow it was like obvious that
the numbers would be the main like parts
that we put we should count the
frequencies on
and we were thinking of having a demo
and was like
for each kind of this natural language
processing tasks we come up with
some kind of same term frequency
versus the modal performance but
the question is now what are the terms
that are important in each of these
questions and this can definitely be a
test of language models performance for
any kind of tasks once we answer the
questions like this
i wanted to talk a little bit about what
you think the future of ml devops and ml
engineering is so it feels to me as i
said it feels like the process is broken
it feels very linear uh it feels like we
have this brittle interface between
science and engineering and we have this
notion as well i think of um okay let's
make the whole process non-interactive
and we ingest the data from here and we
do our training and validation we do our
productionization that becomes a
software engineering process but i
always re i don't know whether you
whether you've read about machine
teaching um i was really intrigued by
that from patrice ahmad at microsoft
research and and he's sort of saying
rather than blindly just ingest all the
data and train it and have have human
experts
kind of supervise the process and define
functors if you like to derive more
salient information out of the training
set because the idea is that if you
select more salient information you you
can have an order of magnitude better
sample efficiency on your training but
that that's a completely interactive
process and you might still think of
that as being a bottleneck
and then i'm thinking is is there a way
to introduce a kind of active learning
framework here to
continuously improve the robustness of
models as an ongoing concern rather than
it being a one hit just wondered whether
you folks had thought about anything
yeah so i think uh with marco we've been
discussing this and and he has uh some
collaborations going on as well uh where
i think what we're realizing is at least
for nlp and maybe we are getting there
with vision as well um you can sort of
say okay given limited time like hey if
i had only 10 minutes and i had to think
about the the variety or diversity in
language it's very difficult for me as a
human being to be super creative about
things whereas if we take uh gpd 3 or
any of these large language models and
think of them as assistants um
they can really generate very
huge diversity of phrasings and
paraphrases and and and negations and
all these other things that we might
want to be testing for and so i think
whether the active part of it is from
the model side or or just using these
language models as tools
it's also something to discuss but i
think definitely testing can become more
interactive even if you don't think
about the target model just by using
gpd3 and all of these things to sort of
push
push our creativity in terms of what
these tests should look like in terms of
actual testing of a model
i'm a little bit concerned about how
active
we should be um
because then the tests might end up
being a little bit too specific to the
model that you are working with um and
next week when you have a different
model or a different architecture
or or you want to use google's language
model rather than open ais
things may change so much that your
tests may not be super reliable
at the end of the day so i i'm all for
minimizing users effort in testing uh
but it's a little bit we have to be
careful about making it too
specific to the target model because
things change
and they change a lot faster i imagine
in industry than they would in research
like we are happy with uh playing with
bird for a couple years and then
switching to something else
because we don't have a stream of data
coming in we don't have customers
complaining about our models and uh
and people trying to hack things into
the model to improve it slightly um and
having a testing framework that is
robust to changes
or even to multiple models that you're
serving at the same time uh
is kind of useful
thinking a bit about the future uh from
here if we if we assume let's say let's
suppose we agree that uh your paper
essentially proves that that these long
large language models are not doing
reasoning at least not for
multiplication
and maybe elsewhere um and if we posit
that reasoning is important you know
that we need to have systems that can
reason what's missing from
large language models today that are
preventing them from reasoning is it
just more parameters like we need maybe
you know 100 times as many more
parameters is it just we need better
data or is there something fundamentally
missing from the current structure
that's needed in order for them to
learn how to reason
i um
i can say by the evidence now like
gopher paper has this uh
like lesson learned from the
parameters and model size
that the models are not getting that
much better in terms of specific
mathematical reasoning that we study by
the number of parameters
so
but at the same time as the models get
really really larger they change
characteristics and personality but
i don't think it's parameter size
i like to see some
symbolic ways maybe that be
more interpretable and i can be sure
that the model is following some kind of
rules while coming up with this
reasoning
but i don't know
yeah i mean i think this is a pretty
important question for us to be thinking
about because there is like i feel like
if there is
in all the data whatever that means like
not even stuff that exists like if you
can make up equations and throw it as
text and then things like that and if
there are enough parameters
theoretically i don't see why
it should not be able to reason like you
can create pathways you can create a
connection so that a transformer can do
addition of any number of digits yeah
you can probably do that if you are not
constrained by number of parameters the
the question ends up being what's the
pragmatic solution to get to
intelligence right and is scaling up
is there enough data to be even getting
there and then is there the number of
parameters and and the monitoring
modulus modularization
that you need in the thing um
uh
is that going to just emerge
automatically or do you have to enforce
it so i think
one idea that i like and i'm not sure
how practical it is is to make language
models um give them access to some
some computing things right like so give
them a calculator
give them access to like a knowledge
graph or or give them access to
something that's a little bit symbolic
and during training if they want to use
it if they find it useful
for the language modeling task maybe
they'll learn to rely on these symbolic
uh functions um which i feel much more
comfortable saying would would
generalize more because they're not
necessarily memorizing right so
it's just one of those things where
language models started by
being language models and now they're a
little bit more world models that are
modeling everything about
uh stuff that goes beyond just
linguistic structure of these sentences
um
and we sort of don't really
rely completely on memorization we know
how to use these other tools when we are
trying to do any tasks and maybe
language models and the right way to get
reasoning is to
let them delegate some of that to to
things that are solved already and then
focus on the more intelligent part of uh
of part of what's needed
yeah i think um my only concern with
that line of argumentation is it's very
similar to
what some of these
fans of large language models say which
is basically the appeal to infinity
similar to the uh the aixa um you know
hutter's um intelligent uh intelligence
argument you're kind of saying that um
if you memorize infinity then it will be
intelligent well that that seemed i
don't know in my opinion that that kind
of misses the point i did it
it's a little bit like we did we're
dealing with all of these curses aren't
we in machine learning you know it's the
curse of dimensionality the curse of
optimization the the approximation error
um
it just it doesn't seem possible to
memorize everything so surely that there
must be a different goal here yeah yeah
i agree with that actually yeah so i
mean i think
uh especially like when the world
evolves new things happen all the time
and we want to be able to have uh models
that sort of adjust to that without
requiring uh you to have already seen
them right like that's a
obvious consequence of what memorization
cannot handle um and so yeah like
finding ways to have these models that
are able to take pieces of information
and put them together in ways that
resembles reasoning uh seems important
and then just being able to evaluate
them properly is is the first step here
and that that seems to really kind of
drive
i think the approach uh yazama was was
indicating that was just some type of a
hybrid
hybrid system like some some system that
has neurosymbolic was symbolic and i
mean
is that right yeah i would say so yeah
yeah i think then then the question is
are you using the symbolic system to
kind of enumerate all of the state space
to memorize in the neural network hash
table or is the
is the symbolic model the first class
model and we're just using the neural
network hash table for those problems in
the perception domain that would have
been brittle
yes that's the kind of thing the
robustness testing of these neural
hybrid modeling should be doing right so
i think
whether
if you introduce these the symbolic
modules inside these language models
then the evaluation step would be is the
language model using them appropriately
or is it using them
the wrong way
we want to get to a stage where we are
asking those kind of questions and we
are confident about the answers we are
getting and we are pretty far from that
right now fantastic well uh yazon and
samir thank you so much for joining us
today it's been an absolute honour yeah
thank you thank you this is great
amazing